-Our next guest
is a fantastic comedian
whose new book,
"You're Doing Great!
And Other Reasons to Stay
Alive," is available now.
He's also the host
of the podcast
"Breaking Bread with Tom Papa."
Please welcome to the show
Tom Papa.
Welcome to the show, Tom,
and I do want to start by saying
that your book is in
the catbird seat here.
I'm displaying it with my copy
of "The Thorn Birds."
-Oh, I'm so -- I can't
tell you how honored I am.
Because I have in my --
When I was growing up,
we had "The Thorn Birds."
I think it was also
with "Lonesome Dove."
-Oh, that's a good one.
"Lonesome Dove" is a good one.
-It's a good one. And to see my
book on that pile, I can't --
I can't lie, I've been
waiting for this moment.
-We're happy to have you here.
And I want to talk
about the book.
But we saw each other last year.
You are an incredibly
accomplished, talented comedian.
But I saw you give
an absolutely perfect --
pitch-perfect performance
as a pastor.
You married Colin Quinn
and Jen Sochko,
who is a producer on our show.
And you have actually married
some other comedians.
Is this correct?
-Yeah, Colin was actually
my fifth one that I've done.
I did Rachel Feinstein's
and Noam Dworman,
who owns the Comedy Cellar,
and Lenny Marcus.
I became, like,
the go-to guy for weddings.
-I tracked you down that night
to compliment the job you did,
because, you know, I think doing
comedy in front of comedians
is hard enough as it is.
-Yeah.
-But to do it on a night that
everyone is going to remember.
Do you --
Versus regular joke-writing,
do you feel that pressure when
you're writing...like that?
-Ooh. [ Chuckles ] Yeah.
I mean, I wrote that thing
for six months straight.
I just kept writing
and writing and writing.
And especially knowing
that it's Colin Quinn,
who is one of the most
prolific, funniest,
and judgmental comedians
we have...
standing this far from my face,
I was -- Oh, the pressure,
every word, every line.
And you were really funny
at the end of it
because you pointed out the
worst part of the whole thing
is, even if it goes well,
which it did, thank God --
that's the only time
you get to do it.
-Yeah.
-And you said you've given
some commencement speeches
and things like that
and you've worked so hard,
and then, poof, it's just gone.
-Yup. You wrote this book,
and you obviously put
a lot of work into this.
And then it's called
"You're Doing Great!
And Other Reasons
to Stay Alive."
But obviously this was written
before a pandemic hit
and basically came out
as this was happening.
Were you -- Because this is
a book that is optimistic.
Were you worried that
optimistic message right now
would not be
what people would want?
And what have you found
the outcome to be?
-Yeah, you know, the line "And
Other Reasons to Stay Alive,"
I thought it was just
being funny.
[ Laughs ] You know?
I didn't know it was
going to be that relevant.
But when the first, like,
two weeks of the shutdown,
the shelter at home,
I had to go do the audio book.
So I drove in L.A. --
only car on the road,
very secretive --
went to, like,
an undisclosed location.
One guy with a mask.
And I was conscious of that.
I was like, when I read this,
is it going to --
is it going to be
trite or shallow?
You know,
because it is optimistic.
And it's about being hopeful
despite having hard times.
And it actually really held up.
It made it seem -- It actually
made me wake up to the idea
that hope is something
I really cherish
and always want
and work hard on keeping.
And it's easy when things
are going pretty good.
It's always -- To be like,
"Yeah, I'm pretty hopeful,
things are going to work out."
But when things are heavy,
to be hopeful,
that's the real challenge
of being hopeful.
And that's where the book
kind of really
just took on
a little bit more resonance.
-You recognized
coughing as a problem
before we were
in the middle of this.
You believe this nation
has an epidemic of coughing.
-[ Laughs ] Yeah.
In the book, I do call out
a couple of moments
that are like, "Oh."
I was flying a lot, you know,
as a touring comedian.
And I say in the book --
I'm like, "Look.
I know the scientists are
working on some big things.
We've got cancer.
We've got some heart disease.
But there's a coughing
epidemic going on.
Every flight I'm on,
people are hacking up a lung.
Please, let's put
some money towards that."
-[ Laughs ] Yeah.